buonasera e oltre il food la riscoperta
del cibo come nutrimento ormai un mantra
intanto volevo ringraziare tutti gli
organizzatori perché parlare di cucina
in un ted non è una cosa così scontata e
banale perché pare che sia un argomento
non così nobile come gli altri ma in
realtà lo è è molto più nobile di quello
che possiamo immaginare
beh intanto mi presento mi chiamo anna e
ho avuto un'infanzia gastronomicamente
molto difficile e però forse è proprio
per merito nella mia mamma e della sua
diciamo idiosincrasia nei confronti dei
fornelli che io sono qui oggi a parlarvi
proprio di cibo perché invece per me il
cibo è sempre stato fin da piccola
proprio forse in contrasto con quella
mamma una cosa molto importante e adesso
questo è il mio mantra più cibo meno
food
non so se sicuramente insomma siamo
tutti italiani quasi qui e se usiamo una
parola straniera se usiamo una parola
inglese è perché vogliamo prendere la
parola italiana un po più intrigante un
po più smart e quindi dire food sembra
molto meglio che dire cibo io spero che
alla fine di questo talk la penserete
esattamente al contrario non di rete più
food ma ricomincerete a dire cibo l'uomo
è ciò che mangia
ne abbiamo parlato persino prima
parlando di notizie non si può iniziare
uno speech di cibo senza citare firebug
in questo senso
è un senso molto filosofico è un senso
antico e quindi riprende il mens sana in
corpore sano quindi un cervello che
funziona deve essere nutrito nella
maniera corretta
c'è un famosissimo storico della cucina
al più famoso credo in italia massimo
montanari che ha ribaltato il concetto e
ha detto che mangiamo ciò che siamo
ovvero il nostro processo di produzione
del cibo e noi fa parte della nostra
storia della nostra cultura e quindi in
sostanza mangiamo tutta la nostra storia
in fondo se ci pensate quando parliamo
di cucina è vero che parliamo di una
piccola parte della nostra vita
ma intanto è la parte che ci fa stare in
vita e non è male
e poi è un piccolo pezzo di tutto quello
che è la storia del di noi che fa parte
proprio di noi e quindi questa è la
slide che riassume le prime due è la mia
versione dei fatti una versione dei
fatti che mi rappresenta molto sono una
persona molto concreta
ciò che mangiamo diventa noi lo ripeto
ciò che mangiamo diventa noi ovvero
quello che noi mettiamo in bocca non
passa solo dentro di noi ma ci fa
diventa noi ci torneremo alla fine come
abbiamo comunicato il cibo nel passato e
come lo stiamo comunicando nel presente
vi ha portato due video perché secondo
me sono molto significativi per capire
qual è stato il passaggio che ha fatto
diventare il cibo food no ve la fate
partire voi no è un classico
potevo inciampare entrando oppure poteva
non partire il video non parte video ma
adesso partirà è mario soldati e non si
sente tanto bene solo ok questo facciamo
a vedere i nostri telespettatori e la
salama da sugo ferrarese cruda sono due
sarà me la sala ma si chiama la sala e
adesso vediamo le stesse cose della cosa
vuole spiegare ai nostri telespettatori
come si cuoce la salama da solo tifosi a
bagnomaria a bagno per legno ma rimane
carrello che cede il suo umorismo si
indaghi asino e non è il sud che ma neve
saranno stesso alone di sì perché poi
con di teco anche vino e liquori e la
sala ma saranno senza creare che dentro
ayad vino il vino cognac e parolo sì
signore cognac e valore ma non evita
salette l'ha rimesso nel sudan al
dall'impasto cioè la sala ma cruda ora
sarebbe mai date a dentro vene fatti il
vino e il coni ha colto tutte le altre
cose di beppe bene lo so state
sorridendo è evidente è un tipo di
comunicazione che non ci appartiene
siamo in un'epoca completamente diversa
ma come vedete è molto didascalico molto
preciso vuole raccontare la storia della
sala ma la scelta apposta per farvi
sorridere dai e lui era un grande
divulgatore era una persona che
raccontava l'italia attraverso tutte le
sue particolarità è tutto il territorio
attraverso proprio il cibo
oggi che cosa succede oggi credo che sia
il momento storico almeno in italia in
cui il cibo è più presente dovunque i
video di cucina si sprecano andiamo dai
tutorial su youtube per imparare a fare
qualunque cosa
ai grandi show di cucina
tutto questo spettacolo muove anche
molti interessi molti soldi e il cibo
viene trattato così
no così sì vieni qui con tutto quello
ambaradan lì e poi il piatto fa cagare
ti do una valutazione un po la corsa va
bene le strisce è successo
and you my friend
credo che non sia quello che il cibo
meriti da merita questo e food quello di
prima era cibo forse dovremmo trovare un
modo altrettanto didascalico quindi
prendendo dal passato
altrettanto spettacolo spettacolarizzato
senza arrivare a gettare via il cibo per
dimostrare che non è stato impiantato
bene o l'abbinamento tra gli alimenti
non era di di grande appeal o
semplicemente il concorrente non era
particolarmente ben accetto rispetto a
questi famosi giudici come si fa questo
bisogna ragionarci sopra perché non è
non è facile non è facile soprattutto
nel momento in cui in cui siamo e nel
momento editoriale in cui siamo sul
futuro beh sul futuro del cibo in
generale mentre preparavo questo talk ho
incontrato il mio amico luca non lo
vedevo da un anno era molto dimagrito
lui era molto
perdonami luca era grasso adesso è magro
gli ho chiesto come aveva fatto e lui mi
ha detto conosce il silent in quanti
conoscete in silent pochi bene il silent
o la sua versione
la sua versione europea il joyland sono
dei beveroni sostanzialmente questa è la
home page si possono comprare online
ovviamente il silent lo comprate solo
negli stati uniti il joyland lo potete
comprare anche in italia vi arriva a
casa una bella scatola non serve il
frigorifero perché questo silent è una
polvere in realtà ed è stata inventata
dal solito studente americano e vabbè
sono più bravi che dobbiamo fare
stavano ragionando non è uno solo
studente un gruppo di studenti stavano
lavorando ad una start up e non avevano
più soldi
l'unica cosa sulla quale potevano
tagliare era il cibo e quindi hanno
pensato ma in fondo noi ci nutriamo
ancora come si nutrivano quegli uomini
delle caverne perché non facciamo altro
che cacciare o coltivare e cuocere delle
cose e mangiarle tutta questa attività
provoca in realtà uno spreco di risorse
di energia notevole ci sarà un modo
migliore per nutrirci in fondo noi
mangiamo il cibo ma noi non serve
mangiare il cibo a noi servono i
nutrimenti che il c i nutrienti che il
cibo ci dà giusto e quindi perché non
mangiare semplicemente perché non
nutrirsi semplicemente di silent in
questo beverone secondo tutti gli studi
che sono stati fatti ne sono stati fatti
tanti
non ci sono controindicazioni
anzi addirittura nutrendoli conquest
questa polvere diluita nell'acqua voi
state meglio perché perché nessuno di
noi potrà mai fare nutrendosi
naturalmente un alimentazione
completamente corretta completamente
equilibrata e bilanciata con questo sì
certo dovete mangiare solo questo
secondo voi è possibile ce la faremo
non lo so però questo è un pezzo di
futuro è un pezzo di futuro che è lì e
si potrebbe anche esplorare ma perché
secondo me questo pezzo di futuro non
funziona perché vi siete mai chiesti
perché mangiamo mangiamo sicuramente
perché dobbiamo stare in piedi lo
abbiamo fatto anche prima molto bene tra
l'altro poi dobbiamo anche stare con gli
altri è un atto sociale poi dobbiamo
ragionarci sopra perché comunque ripeto
quello che ho detto all'inizio quello
che mangiamo diventa noi e poi perché fa
parte della nostra cultura soprattutto
in italia e quindi forse il silent da
solo tutto questo
non ce lo può offrire il mio chef lo
chef con cui lavoro da da sempre da
vent'anni dice sempre questa cosa un
cibo per essere il migliore al mondo
deve avere cinque caratteristiche
fondamentali deve essere sano e questa è
la prima caratteristica ricordatevelo
soprattutto quando cucinate a casa voi
potreste fare la cosa più buona del
mondo ma se poi mi fate stare male non
funziona quindi sano buono certo per
forza tra l'altro dicono che il silent
siamo non lo so non ho ancora provato
non lo proverò deve essere buono quindi
deve deve avere delle caratteristiche
che il mio palato ma non solo mio
parlato anche la mia cultura percepisce
come buona deve essere economico ma non
economico nel senso deve costare poco
nel mio range di scelta io posso
scegliere le ostriche più buona del
mondo e le patate è più buona del mondo
e pagarle il giusto prezzo
il giusto prezzo e qui entriamo anche
nel nell'aspetto etico deve essere il
prezzo giusto per quell alimento ma per
tutto quello che c'è dietro quell
alimento quindi per i contadini che
lavorano la terra per coltivare le
patate o i pescatori che vanno a pescare
il pesce che io mangerò e per tutta la
filiera che che ne consegue quindi
abbiamo detto deve essere sano deve
essere buono deve essere economico deve
essere bello perché anche l'occhio vuole
la sua parte diciamo e perché comunque
una uno dei primi sensi che viene
colpito quando iniziamo a mangiare e
l'occhio avete mai pensato che mangiare
insieme forse solo a un'altra cosa
coinvolge tutti e cinque i vostri sensi
quando mordete anche l'udito è coinvolto
lo toccate per forza lo guardate e poi
lo mangiate e vabbè lascio a voi è
scoprire quale altra cosa e poi deve
essere
facile da consumare dovete poterlo
mangiare in piedi con una mano sola
mentre state facendo anche altro secondo
il mio chef secondo in realtà quasi
quasi tutti gli chef se un piatto riesce
ad avere tutte queste cinque
caratteristiche è un piatto che avrà
grande successo vi viene in mente un
piatto così italiano bravi ad andare
oltre
andare oltre il food e ritornare a
parlare di cibo vuol dire riscoprire il
valore fondamentale del cibo ovvero il
il fatto che un nostro nutrimento non
dimenticarci mai che per noi può essere
un gioco può essere un divertimento
mater gran parte del resto del mondo è
ancora un problema da risolvere è forse
il silent in quel senso potrebbe essere
un modo per risolverlo mi sono
dimenticata di dirvi che costa veramente
poco tipo 2 o 3 dollari per ogni pasto
quindi ha dei vantaggi non indifferenti
abbiamo visto quello che perdiamo e vero
però volevo chiudere con con una domanda
alla quale faccio fatica a rispondere ma
ma magari insieme riusciremo a trovare
questa risposta
la comunicazione ha aiutato ho cambiato
il nostro modo di mangiare di intendere
il cibo ovviamente la risposta è sì non
solo con la pubblicità noi siamo pronti
diciamo così a lo sappiamo la pubblicità
è fatta per convincerci ad acquistare
qualcosa che magari non vorremmo che non
sappiamo di volere ma spesso la
comunicazione del cibo è falsata anche
in altri modi ma anche dal punto di
vista editoriale non so vi faccio due
esempi la lo scandalo che c'è stato
pochi mesi fa della
della carne rossa e degli insaccati
quasi tutti i giornali per un periodo
hanno titolato con titoli scioccanti non
si poteva più mangiare la carne rossa
giusto perché saremo tutti morti di
cancro se avessimo mangiato la carne
rossa un utilizzo pessimo del mezzo
informativo e un inutile allarmismo nei
confronti delle persone che ha avuto
delle ricadute pesanti sia sulla nostra
vita quotidiana perché moltissime
persone hanno smesso veramente di
mangiare la carne rossa in maniera del
tutto insensata ma anche per esempio sui
produttori di carne e sui marcella i che
hanno visto crollare in qualche modo un
loro asset importante quindi attenzione
grandissima attenzione quando parliamo
di questo argomento perché se sbagliamo
nella recensione di un cantante faremo
dei danni al cantante dall'industria
discografica è vero ma quello non avrà
un'influenza diretta su di noi e sul
nostro corpo sulla nostra vita perché
quando parliamo di cibo parliamo proprio
di questo e non dobbiamo assolutamente
mai dimenticarcelo
e quindi io spero che il mio mantra
dell'inizio quindi più cibo meno food
diventi anche il vostro e spero che la
prossima volta che andrete al
supermercato e deciderete di scegliere
la bottiglia d'olio per la vostra
insalata non spenderete di meno di
quanto spendete quando andrete dal
meccanico e vi farete cambiare il vostro
olio nella vostra auto vi prego fatelo
per me grazie